well uh now for the main event of the
evening again the resolution reads the
New York Times book The 1619 project and
the hula video series based on it are
important contributions to our
understanding of slavery and the role of
African Americans in American history
yes no or undecided on the resolution
here to defend the resolution Professor
Woody Holton Woody please come to the
stage
[Applause]
taking taking the negative on the
resolution historian Phil Magnus from
aier Phil please come to the stage
[Applause]
Jane please close the voting of Woody
Holton okay shake hands and come out
fighting guys okay and uh Woody Holton
you have 18 minutes to speak for the
affirmative take it away Woody all right
thank you
thank you so much Jane for the warm warm
welcome I love talking about the 1619
project but especially tonight because
it seems like I was a bit Lucky in the
timing
because it's 4 20. a day to talk about
freedom and about Freedom Fighters like
those who people this book
I'm going to say that racism is still in
the Woodwork of some of our most
powerful institutions in this country
and most countries uh and I think Phil
is going to say that it's mostly down at
this point to a few crazies this seems
like more good timing for me though
because as you all know just a few days
ago three nine-year-olds were murdered
in Tennessee and three members of the
state legislature joined an Iraqis
protest and then two of those members
were expelled
and I think you all know which two
this book
embarrasses me
I've been teaching for 30 years and I
keep learning more every time I read
another part of this book for instance
who here raise your hand if you will
please and I want to come out in front
of the lights to see you who here can
raise your hand like me and say they'd
never heard of J Marion's or who has
heard of J Marion Sims before
I don't see a single hand in this room I
see one keep it up if you know that he's
the father of Gynecology known as the
father of gon College still up keep it
up if you know that many of his
techniques still in use today still up
keep it up if you know that he learned
these techniques by experimenting on
enslaved women against their con without
their consent you know all of them
there's one person in the room and maybe
it's because you've read the 1619
project now there's two because I've
read it as well one thing I did know
about was what we used to call the
Wilmington race ride of
1898 but what I didn't know until I read
this book that it was more than just
white North Carolinians murdering dozens
of black North Carolinians it was a coup
that overthrew the elected government of
Wilmington most stunning of all for me
was that on September 22nd 1862 when
Lincoln issued his Emancipation
Proclamation he was still toying with
the idea of colonizing black Americans
somewhere outside of the borders of the
of the United States that's the
Emancipation Proclamation and there it
says I Abraham Lincoln so I'm not lying
and there's uh what he says uh persons
of African elements upon the continent
I'm sorry I missed the key word and that
the effort to colonize persons of
African uh descent upon the continent or
elsewhere will continue that's in the
Emancipation Proclamation the
preliminary aversion that he issued on
right after the battle of Sharpsburg or
Antietam as you call it up here
um so this is a book that's full of
surprises and useful in that sense
um Gene when you invited me to I'm here
tonight my first thought was really
you're going to have two white guys
debate in the 1619 project but then I
realized you what you were thinking
which is
on this topic we're the ignorant ones
and we need this more than most people
and so I'm very glad to be a part of it
I found in this book not only
information but inspiration from getting
to know people like uh MacArthur cotton
he was as you see from Greenwood
Mississippi joined Snick and got
involved in civil rights protests which
of course got him thrown in jail and not
just that but they did this they tied
them up like this and hung him from the
highest bar of his cell so that only his
tiptoes were touching and he said he
nearly died because they did this for
days and he describes this in the Hulu
video to while he's being interviewed by
Nicole Hannah Jones talks about his
pants filling with feces and she just
started to cry
and she started to apologize too on
behalf and he said no no no
that's not it and and what he said was
something that I heard a lot from World
War II veterans including my father and
that was just use the freedoms we
sacrificed for
another inspiring person in the Hulu
videos is Nicole herself for instance
the story she tells of being a child
back in Waterloo Iowa and the teacher
assigned the kids draw the flag of the
country uh back in the old world that
your ancestors are from so they set to
work Germany Irish for Irish flag and
all that and she was
what do I do my people are from all up
and down the African Coast what flag do
I draw
until finally this child sat down at her
desk and she Drew the American flag
because black Americans were made in the
USA
um now if I look at the book as a
historian rather than as an individual
it's most important contribution has
been its success at taking facts and
events that we Specialists and just
Old-Timers like me have always known
about but haven't really gotten it out
to the wider world and it's really
conveyed those ideas to The Wider what
we call it public history so I got one
more raise your hand uh raise your hand
if you knew that on May 13th
1985 Philadelphia
Dropped a Bomb on a black vegetarian
commune in West Philly and they killed
11 people five of whom was children
raise your hand so that's a larger group
I think it's an older group too so you
know like I Do's most of you by by being
there I mean being around when that
happened but that's the sort of thing
that our younger generation doesn't know
and in my opinion should no Carol
Anderson has an article in in this book
where she draws a straight line from
blacks trying to defend themselves
against the Lynch Mob a hundred years
ago which usually just got more of them
killed a straight line to their having
much less success than whites do today
at using the stand your ground defense
Anderson also shows that in 1967 when
black panthers in Oakland started open
carrying you could open carry in in
California at the time but when they
started doing it California's assembly
rushed to ban open carry and one of the
authors of that gun ban was an official
with the NRA
Matthew Desmond Desmond gives us a
financial history of slavery showing
that planners like Thomas Jefferson
often raised Capital by mortgaging
slaves and that in flavors used very
sophisticated accounting techniques to
track slaves output and actually more
sophisticated than a lot of factories
were using at the time to track their
workers but their goal of course was to
be able to ratchet up their output which
they mostly did through better seeds
what they did to the extent they could
by tracking and getting more work out of
the slaves it's the sort of thing that
Frederick Taylor would become famous for
doing but he was bought in like 19 I'm
sorry like 1854 so he does all of that
after the Civil War following the
workers around the around the factory
with his stopwatch kind of like Amazon
does with their warehouse workers today
that's all after this was done on
plantations and I thought that was
fascinating but I also got to admit that
I don't think the Desmond article
measures up to the others in this book
he does tell us that slave gun cotton
was our number one crop in the 19th
century but and that's true but it's the
understatement of the year because by
1850 our cotton experts were exports
were larger than all of our other
exports combined and I don't just mean
all of our other crops yes all of our
other crops but also everything else
that you could possibly think to add
into the basket that was exported by the
United States was worth less than the
cotton was in 1850 and in 1860 but even
if you want to forget about exports
industrialism began in the United States
in the cotton mill the cotton mill that
got its input from enslaved people and
sold it and it's for whom the cut most
the customers were slaves as TW as well
and Desmond misses all that and he
misses that in the 18th century this was
also true everybody knows about southern
tobacco which was the number 1 colonies
from the British North American colony
crop and rice but even northern colonies
like this one right here depended just
as heavily on slaves because the Middle
Colonies and New England were only able
to participate in the 18th century
Merchant capitalist Revolution by
sending grain wood livestock and I love
speaking of Connecticut as cowboy
country but it was uh in the in the 18th
century that was one of their main
exports all of that going to lots of
places but predominantly oh and fish
from New England must not forget that to
the enslavers on the Caribbean islands
like Jamaica all of that in return
mostly for molasses which comes back to
North America and gets distilled into
rum and that's our first manufacturing
really
in the period of late colonies and in
Independence was that rum men those rum
uh
distilleries and I'm sorry to say that
Desmond missed all of that which is a
real lost opportunity one thing that the
1619 project does rail does nail is
really close to my heart and that is how
enslaved people helped inadvertently
bring about the independence decision on
the part of whites and so let me let me
take you back to September of 1774. the
Patriots massively outnumbered the
British and so enslaved people in that
month started going to the British
officials and saying
we know you need Fighters we'll fight
for you if you will promise uh to free
it and eventually the Royal governors of
all of the southern colonies
um agreed to agreed to to this I mean
District
and this what an official Alliance Inked
in Paris but this informal alliance
between the British and the blacks
infuriated white Americans even many who
oppose slavery and I'll give you a
couple of examples now Phil I know you
don't like it when I quote common sense
but that's where Thomas Paine wrote that
in America there were tens of thousands
who would think it glorious to expel
that barbarous and hellish power Britain
which has stirred up the Indians and
Negroes to destroy it and like Thomas
Paine Ben Franklin opposed slavery but
you know what he did after the British
made this alliance with blacks he
designed a propaganda poster and in it
the Brits get black men to kill white
men and carry off their wives and
daughters an early case of white
smearing men of color as rapists
something that you've seen in this town
in 2015 at the bottom of the golden
escalator this slaves not the British
had initiated that Alliance but numerous
whites accused the British of
pointing a dagger to their throats
through the hands of their slaves whites
were already angry at British government
in 1774 over taxes trade bunch of stuff
but their fear and their Fury at this
anglo-black Alliance helped push many
whites over the edge into declaring
independence and we have known that
since 1958 when Benjamin Quarles
um oh there's the I'm behind my slide
I'm ahead of my slides that's Benjamin
Quarles at Morgan State he published
this article in that year and then three
years later this book
talking about blacks and the revolution
in general and especially about their
alliance with the British we've known
that but the word didn't get out until
the the
the the 1619 project uh brought it about
so I see I only have five more minutes
seemed like a lot less to me but
um that always happens on your speaker
so I'm going to skip through some of
these uh things uh evidence of the black
uh White oh the black British Alliance
having such a big impact
um and just say that I put 76 of these
documents where whites complain about
the alliance between the British and the
blacks I put 76 of them up on Twitter
and uh and made a bitly where you can
get them oh yeah that's going to take it
for all it's going to take a while for
all those to load sorry
um can I borrow some of my later time
you're not allowed to do that are you uh
that'll that'll load in a second and
I'll and I'll keep going and so I think
what really the 1619 project did was
they don't claim to do anything new but
they have exposed to non-historians
these discoveries that we've been made
but then here comes the problem like the
splendors of Rome the 1619 projects
booming success attracted Lords and
hordes of vandals determined to tear it
all down
the ostensible reason for their
indignation is that the original version
of the 1619 project so Tran and 16 in
the Times magazine in 2019 contained
errors and so look at some of the things
that prompted them to call it
incompetent unscholarly all this oh even
disgusting uh uh um yeah all of those
are just filled by the way
the 1619 authors corrected most of their
mistakes in the book but the haters
continue not just to criticize the book
but to ostracize it to say it's beyond
the pale outside the wire I guess in
Britain they'd say into touch
Phil told uh Michelle Tafoya that in the
1619 project
I'll just put up his statement
um
but uh and you also told her that in the
both the book and the but the point that
I want to make is that you and I also
make mistakes Phil I made them in my
book a liberty Suite on sale in the
lobby
um
but here's here's one I want to be sure
to get to we're going to play Spot the
differences and listen carefully to
Phil's description on in a Washington
Times podcast about my 15 minutes or 15
seconds of Glory on Hulu it's already
underway Holton stands up and he points
at the door of the governor's Palace and
basically says from that building Comes
This Proclamation and that building
represents the crown Authority he makes
it sound as it's like Dunmore walked to
the door of the building and uh pulled
out a piece of paper and had it read to
the colonists that I am freeing your
slaves but none of this happened at all
so I'm sorry that didn't come out better
that was yellow in my in my version it
comes down to three got it two minutes
it comes down to three things I said he
has me doing three things one
uh standing up two pointing at the
governor's Palace and then three saying
that's the building where Dunmore issued
his Proclamation
shall we go to the videotape and that
Emancipation Proclamation
infuriated white Southerners because
this building is supposed to symbolize
white rule over blacks and now the guy
inhabiting that building has turned
things upside down and is leading blacks
against whites so it's the most trivial
thing in the world but I didn't stand up
I didn't point and I didn't say that was
the building from which done more uh
issued uh his Proclamation and I'm not
mad Phil you're better's version your
version is better than what really
happened it was just two soccer parents
sitting on a bench
um but I do want you to get off the high
horse and live in this and realize that
you live in the same house where the
rest of us live
um oh here's one more I just can't
resist mentioning in your book
um
it's correct to have the last name first
in your bibliography because it's
alphabetized but not in the footnotes
it's first name first last name last and
the first names don't even happen at all
uh after first you got it right in some
of them but not not in the majority the
point is we all make mistakes I see the
30 second warning so I'm going to skip
some stuff and just say this
we are brought we are capacious enough
in our minds to contain the fact that
Thomas Jefferson both owned 600 people
and wrote those Immortal words about all
of us being created equal
some people see that as unpatriotic to
point out to the fact that he was a
complex person but I don't and I would
urge you to reject the blood and soil
patriotism that requires us to worship
our white ancestors and instead Embrace
a truly American patriotism where our
loyalty is to our principles and we
trust our children with the truth thank
you
[Applause]
thank you
and judging you you get an extra 30
seconds fair enough
and you know thank you
all right thank you everyone for joining
us
this is a fun topic and one that I've
been engaged in a variety of public
debates about for the past I guess we're
coming up on uh just over three years
now since it's really burst under the
national scene but the 1619 project as
we have seen has gone through multiple
iterations now I'd like to note The
Prompt tonight has a very specific
language in it for a reason
that reason is we're debating whether
the lose the microphone we are debating
whether the New York Times book The 1619
project and Hulu video series based on
it are important contributions to our
understanding of the role of slavery and
history
I'm taking the negative proposition on
that
but with a Twist
and that twist is I actually do believe
that the original 1619 project has
appeared in the New York Times in August
2019 had the potential to become a
viable interesting and important
contribution to African-American history
it was a flawed contribution
and one that was subject to debate
and one that originally invited debate
but what's happened in the course of the
event since then is through the
editorship of Nicole Hannah Jones and
the leadership of the New York Times
They veered off course
rather than engaging that debate on a
scholarly basis they moved into politics
and in so doing they began to backfill
and retrofit bits and pieces of History
to prop up the weaker parts of their
story in response to criticism
those bits and pieces sometimes had
kernels of Truth to them in other cases
they had errors
but they all shared a common theme they
were cherry-picked based on whether they
supported a preconceived narrative
whereas other evidence was excluded
the result
is the 1619 project book in the Hulu
series actually we did the opposite of
improving upon the original 1619 project
of engaging the debate they made it
worse they made it less factual and
above all they made it more ideological
this is what I would call the great
tragedy of the 1619 project because not
only did they make it more ideological
they created a distraction it was
centered really around two to three of
the original dozen or so feature essays
in the 1619 project the lead essay by
Nicole Hannah Jones
captured the majority of attention
followed by the controversy over Matthew
Desmond's SN American capitalism and
these are the main areas I want to dig
into on where the book in Hulu series go
awry
first let's start with the American
Revolution
the original 1619 project had a faulty
but unsubstantiated claim that slavery
was a primary motivator of American
independence
it did so on bits and pieces and kernels
of Truth and evidence such as the
somerset case of 1772 although they
conveniently omitted the fact that
Benjamin Franklin no small player in the
American Revolution
said that the somerset case did not go
far enough in freeing the slaves it only
freed one why not free them all in a
letter to his friend Anthony Ben is a
abolitionist
the version of the 1619 project that was
extended in the book in the Hulu series
though trying to retrofit other
arguments to prop up this original
faulty Claim about slavery's role in the
American Revolution after it came under
Fire not only from critics in the
history profession but from the New York
Times his own fact checker
Leslie Harris wrote an article in
Politico that revealed she warned them
that this was too strong of a claim in
the original version The Times ignored
it
so what did they do they turned to the
document we've mentioned uh Professor
holton's opening remarks the Dunmore
Proclamation of November 1775. I want
you to remember that date November 7
1775 is the day he issues it and it
becomes public on November 15 1775.
this is interesting because the
Revolution was not only well underway
there were armies in the field and in
fact we're going to find out where Lord
Dunmore happened to be on that day
[Music]
Dunmore issued that Emancipation
Proclamation November 1775 and that
Emancipation Proclamation
infuriated white Southerners because
this building is supposed to symbolize
white rule over blacks and now the guy
inhabiting that building has turned
things upside down and is leading blacks
against whites
so you have this situation where many
Virginians and other Southern colonists
they're not really convinced that they
want to side with the Patriots and this
turns many of them towards the
revolution is that right
if you ask them it did the record is
absolutely clear I can't think of a
point that I could make about the
American Revolution where I could
compile as many quotes as I can from
white Southerners saying how Furious
they are that Governor Dunmore some of
them said there's no other expedient you
could have thought of that was as likely
as this to turn us against you
that's an interesting video we've
already seen a little of the clip and I
apologize to Professor Holton I guess he
was seated after all but I do maintain
he pointed at the building you just saw
it
and he said Governor Dunmore inhabited
that building last I checked inhabited
means lived in
where was governor Dunmore at that time
that's an open question let's go back
and review the timeline because I think
we have an anachronism on hand
4-20 1775 in fact the anniversary we
went on today
an incident happened in Williamsburg
Virginia governor Dunmore sent his
Marines Royal Marines in the middle of
the night to capture the gunpowder
stores of the colony of Virginia held in
downtown Williamsburg you can see the
spot today if you go there on the tour
this infuriated the colonists note it
also occurs on a very uh specific time
in history because the day before
we had a similar order issued in
Massachusetts to do the same thing to
the gunpowder stores in a little town
called Concord we know how that happened
nine days later
word from Lexington and Concord reaches
Williamsburg it makes its way down the
coast by then the colonists were
infuriated asking Governor Dunmore why
did you steal the colony's gunpowder
Governor Dunbar comes out with a
statement he issues on May 3rd 1775 he
says
dear colonists I acted in your own
interests I
removed the gunpowder to quote prevent
an indentured an intended Insurrection
of the slaves who have been hovering
around the gunpowder magazine at night
he claimed he was on the side of
suppressing the slave Insurrection on
the exact same day he sends a secret
letter to British command saying I'm
actually acting to remove the gunpowder
from their stores because I think
they're about to declare
Independence or Revolt or engage in
Insurrection of some sort
but nonetheless it infuriates the mob
over the course of the next month there
are several confrontations between
Dunmore and the Virginia House of
Burgesses over this particular incident
as well as an attempt by a fellow by the
name of Patrick Henry
to move a militia around the city of
Williamsburg what does the governor
Dunmore do in that moment well on June 8
he gathers up all the silver in the
governor's Palace and leaves he leaves
with one other thing his own personal
slaves in tow
relocates them to his Plantation several
miles up the river and relocates himself
onto a British warship
remember that date
November 7 1775 where was governor
Dunmore he was not sitting in that
Governor's Palace he was not inhabiting
the palace
he was on a warship out in the
Chesapeake Bay he had been chased out of
the colony basically had his
governorship declared vacant
and lost control of what he purported to
rule over
that's when he issues his Proclamation
that's a key point but it's omitted from
the Hulu series it's omitted from the
discussion of the revised versions of
the 1619 project
issued on that date infuriated
Virginians it absolutely did
it also declared the entire Colony under
a state of Martial law so separate the
part about what it said about slavery
there are plenty of reasons to be upset
at dunmore's Proclamation
but the key point is the Revolution was
underway
when people like Nicole Hannah Jones
attribute this event to Turning Virginia
against the tide we have another
anachronism because one of the people
she names is George Washington
little inconvenient fact there George
Washington six months earlier had been
appointed commander of the Continental
Army I guess he didn't know what he was
commanding or fighting for when this
Proclamation is issued so I think what
we have is a case of playing fast and
loose with bits and pieces of fact that
had kernels of truth behind them
but were exaggerated I'd indeed say
vastly exaggerated that's a quote from
Professor holton's recent book in his
description of the original 1619
Project's attribution of an abolition
movement that was supposedly nascent in
the British Empire at the time
I want to turn to a second point in the
1619 project and that is the subject of
capitalism this in fact I think was the
only essay in the original dozen or so
that came out in the New York Times that
merited complete retraction in fact I
called for it at the time because it was
substantially weaker on its evidentiary
basis in other words Nicole Hannah
Jones's argument in the original could
have been remediated and adjusted and
addressed in a scholarly context with
her interlocutors she chose not to do so
but the Desmond essay what did it do it
made a claim it made a claim about
American capitalism
in this country we tend to think of
slavery as a southern institution but
slavery was our nation's first big
business and it was slave from cotton
that fueled our early economy and helped
turn a fledgling nation into a global
Powerhouse
on the cusp of the Civil War the 10
major Cotton States were producing 66
percent of the world's cotton and raw
cotton accounted for more than half of
all U.S exports
explain for us how the production of
cotton creates an entire financial
industry uh in the nascent United States
so if we said let's start with cotton
and say that this is a world in which
cotton is the equivalent of oil in the
20th century
it is the thing that employs millions of
people far far away from the sites of
actual Cotton production
New York Banks and New York shipping
companies and New York insurance
companies are playing a crucial role in
the transport and sale of slave grown
cotton out of New Orleans if we think
about the labor that's taking place in
New England in the factories of places
like Lowell that are turning slave grown
cotton into cloth that is sold
throughout the United States if you
don't have slave grown cotton you don't
have an American Industrial Revolution
it's as simple as that
heard without cotton there's no
Industrial Revolution and other
historians that contributed to this Hulu
series to the book in advised the 1619
project conveyed even bold their claims
including the claim
that the Western world would not have
broken out of the malthusian Trap of
History had it not been for Plantation
slavery these are extreme and bold
claims but their claims that are not as
new as their articulators have made them
out to be even though they've dubbed
themselves a school of thought called
the new history of capitalism even
though the 1619 project is presented
this is a story that's never been told
it has in fact been told many times
before the most notable being in 1857
when Senator James Henry Hammond of
South Carolina stood up on the floor of
the United States Senate and made the
exact same argument you've probably
heard it before from its most famous
line he declared that cotton is king of
the world economy and waves it scepter
over all wealth that existed in the
United States and indeed abroad
the Confederacy built its entire
economic program around this Theory King
Cotton Theory they waged the Civil War
thinking
that economic interest would come
rushing to their aid from Britain and
France abroad from the northern states
who realized that their economy was
about to tank because if you cut off
cotton you cut off the industry of
wealth for the world
turned out that didn't happen
in fact we see a lopsided contest of
Northern industry just walloping the
South economically throughout the course
of the world
there is no recession or depression that
would have followed as was predicted by
the Confederacy it turned out that King
Cotton was a pretender to the economic
Throne now there are some claims that
are made in that series that do have
nominal basis and Truth indeed cotton
was the United States's largest export
greater than 50 percent in some years
before the Civil War
it also turns out the United States did
not export very much in that era cotton
production
in exports accounted to less than five
percent of U.S GDP in any given year
they've also engaged in another
accounting era of sorts that you just
heard in that video they gave a long
list
of claims
that are supposed to justify
the ubiquitous and indeed dominant
presence of cotton in all aspects of
national production and output every
industry every Financial instrument
every sector now it's not exactly true
that cotton plantations used uh
accounting for the first time in really
sophisticated forms of it although the
original 1619 project they said uh if
you use Microsoft Excel today that
descends from the plant Plantation
accounting books turned out Matthew
Desmond had misread something they did
correct that in the series but they
replaced Microsoft Excel with amazon.com
and Uber so if you used any of those
today you're partaking in apparently a
system that drives from slavery
that's a really strange claim but what
they don't do
is make adjustments on the denominator
they do economic calculations in the
numerator to show Cotton's supposed size
they don't do commensurate adjustments
to railroads to iron production to
non-cotton textiles like wool to
foodstuffs to grains on the denominator
side therefore they don't get an
accurate calculation
what effectively happens
is in the 1619 project Series in book
they reconcile
themselves to the fact that they had
overstated the evidence of the new
history of capitalism School an attempt
to supplant it when new
versions of arguments bits and pieces of
theories one of which comes directly out
of marxian exploitation Theory you'll
see also if you watch the Hulu series a
historian by the name of Robin DG Kelly
basically articulates this he defines
capitalism itself as exploitation of
producer Surplus from the workers
capitalism is inherently exploitative
that's the circularity of an argument
and it's one that's actually at odds
with quite a bit of historical evidence
if you asked people in the mid 19th
century
what side capitalism was on in this
debate over abolition versus slavery
the slave owners detested capitalism in
fact George Fitzhugh one of the leading
Advocates of the slave system of the
South says that what we refer to today
as law say fair Theory capitalism the
descendants of Adam Smith and
Jean-Baptiste say and Frederick bastiat
are at quote at war with all kinds of
slavery everywhere and if you don't
defeat capitalism slavery will not
survive
it's a pretty damning quote but I do
want to end on a positive note
and offer some of praise to the original
version of the 1619 project that was
published in the New York Times in fact
I made this praise at the time it was
published and differed from a lot of the
historian critics and that was over a
point that Professor Holton and I think
probably agree upon that is Abraham
Lincoln's involvement in the
colonization movement on the eve of the
Civil War and into the Civil War
in fact here's a quote from Sean
Williamson the Atlantic where he trashes
the 1619 project for raising the issue
of colonization and connecting it with
Lincoln in fact he asserts that Lincoln
was disingenuous effectively in
proffering colonization to try to lure
people over to the Emancipation
Proclamation not true
Not only was colonization in the
original draft preliminary version of
the Emancipation Proclamation on the
very day that Lincoln signed the final
Emancipation Proclamation January 1st
1863. you know what he did an hour
before that
he met with a contractor for a
colonization company to commission a
ship of 500 freed African Americans to
be relocated to the colony of slave of
Haiti
in fact I've done quite a bit of
research on this particular subject
that research includes whoops
losing my SlideShare that research
includes
I've lost the PowerPoint
is there a way we can bring that back
take issues well I was going to show you
a picture
of a Sugar Mill and Belize that original
documents by Abraham Lincoln
brought to the Forefront uh in 1863 and
in fact July 1863 proved that Abraham
Lincoln continued to pursue colonization
well after the Emancipation Proclamation
quite possibly up to the day that he
died Nicole Hannah Jones recognized this
in originally in the 1619 project when
this was Under Fire she sent out a bunch
of tweets
those tweets said new research new
evidence had come to light that
sustained our position on colonization
one of them included a link to
amazon.com if you clicked on that link
which I was going to show and open for
you it went to a book
I was the author of that book
she sent out another link
to a New York Times piece that was
published in 2013 about Lincoln's
colonization Ventures I was the author
of that piece
someone pointed out to her not long
after this
that this guy Magnus is critiquing you
and what did she do she changed her tone
and this is where I argued that the book
and Hulu series go awry
in punitive retaliation for discovery of
that fact about me she excised that
entire segment and replaced it with a
secondary quote from ebernex candy that
claimed that Abraham Lincoln abolished
colonization now that is not history
that is politicization that is
editorializing in its punitive
propaganda
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
well that is a Twist Phil
to go from being the leading critic the
layout the loudest at least critic of of
the 2019 version of the 1619 project and
they listened to Phil they made
tremendous number of changes they
listened to me too as Phil noticed I've
criticized them for one thing about the
revolution which is they claimed that uh
the British anti-slavery movement was
really strong on the eve of the
Revolution and that that's why people
I've done more issued emancipation
proclamations because they'd somehow got
caught up in that or they they they they
left that possibility as a out there and
it's just wrong and I'll be clear again
tonight as as they are in the in the
book version of the 1619 project the
governor dunmore's Emancipation
Proclamation was a war measure done to
win the war uh not out of any
humanitarianism so they changed that in
response to my suggestions they changed
a lot in Desmond's article uh it was it
had some really crazy stuff about the
Excel spreadsheets now it's inaccurate
to say what you feel said Phil which is
that they
um switched to saying that Amazon is
based on slavery they've just noticed
similarities in the whole speed up a
session of following people around with
a uh with a stopwatch to give them to
move uh faster but my point is you
should be patting yourself on the back
for all the changes that you got between
the 2019 version in the in the New York
Times magazine in the 2021 version and I
Pat you on the back for making those
changes I also Pat them on the back
because to me the mark of a good scholar
is someone who recognizes their mistakes
listens to their critics and makes the
proper changes uh as they as they've
done so I I'm still struggling to see
anything wrong in the book I know one
error in the movie because I made it
myself in trying to explain find this
complex thing that I try to explain to
you guys quickly that Governor Dunmore
was
made this alliance with enslaved people
and that caused them problems
um I I said oh yeah and this is you know
we're sitting in front of his house this
is the house he lived in and it's not
like Lincoln's emancipation because was
Lincoln living in in remind me because
you know this was Lincoln living in in
the White House when he issued
Emancipation Proclamation more
uh yeah actually he was an inhabitant of
a Soldiers Home in Northeast DC when he
issued the preliminary uh Proclamation
somebody Google that where was Lincoln
when he issued the preliminary
Emancipation Proclamation on September
22nd 1862 uh it was cooler up there in
Northeast DC and the whole family was up
there they had a cottage at Soldiers
Home and raise your hand during q a it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter these
are trivial matters and this is what I
worry that you're doing Phil you think
you're trivializing the project but you
trivialize yourself when I I'm in an
interview I'm trying to explain
something complicated I say I forgot
where the guy lived where he lived
didn't matter what he did in the eyes of
white slaveholders was abdicate his
responsibility to protect them from
their slaves and instead aim a dagger at
our throats through the hands of our
slaves I guess I'm going to be as
unsuccessful oh no look this thing's
working again post script is that you
because I want to go back to mine
believe it or not because here's the big
surprise I want to give you you said oh
so the by the time Dunmore issued his
Emancipation Proclamation in November of
1775 there were already armies in the
field and you're right there were armies
in the field by November 1775 but the
first blacks to appeal to the British
and say we'll fight for you if you'll
free us that first happened in September
of
1774. long before there were armies in
the field and even longer before George
Washington on July 3 1775 took them over
in all of these documents I put up of
white Southerners furious at the British
for allying with the blacks because they
did it not just in Virginia but in all
the southern colonies all these
documents are from before November 1775
and by the way he issued that
Proclamation not on November 7th as you
said but November 15th doesn't matter
all of these documents plus 22 more that
I didn't have room for are complaints
and you can see it's not just my
paraphrases these is where I could get
them the documents themselves the
newspapers Etc from the time in 1774 in
the spring of 1775 you described the the
whole issue with the gunpowder that adds
up to 47 of the 76 documents that I put
up that you can go look at on your phone
right now of whites complaining about
this British alliance with slaves
majority of those came from before
Dunmore issued his famous Proclamation
so I just wanted to correct that and I
would also urge you to get off the
conveniently omitted thing but because
anybody can say that anybody else
conveniently omitted something it is
cool that Benjamin Franklin got this
one-liner off after the somerset
decision that hey I wish they'd freed
all the slaves he of course had owned
slaves but didn't at the time
um they were still advertising for
runaway slaves slaves for sale and all
that
um or his his former newspaper was but
um we need to get we need to be straight
about that
um the you said the last time I checked
or we talked to dealt with who inhabited
where neither of them inhabited in the
building uh that uh neither of them was
in the building that they inhabited but
let's not get caught up in silly stuff
like that
um do you you said that whites were mad
at the fact that Dunmore declared
martial law as well as the fact that he
freed slaves tell me some of your
evidence for that
go ahead you got a mic you've got it oh
he's not allowed to talk
well only that got kind of an
opportunity here then
what's that all right when you're when
it's time for you to talk more tell us
gave us some of your quotes I had 76 you
may not have time for us if you've got
76 you may not have time for all of them
on Cotton
if on Cotton um I don't understand how
you can say that cotton was not crucial
well
I can't ask you a question but answer
when when it's your turn what was the
industry that began industrialism in
both the United States and Britain if it
was not the textile industry tell me
what industry it was am I am I out of
time yeah
good night and good luck
[Applause]
yeah
the Q a session you can ask Phil any
question you want so that's when you can
ask Phil your questions yeah but uh
you've you've posed questions from and
challenges
decades yeah but but you can ask
questions yeah all right you can start
off with at least an answer for uh I
know it may be a trivial matter I
actually think it's fairly important to
get the history right because at the end
of the day that's what we are historians
I do know for a fact Abraham Lincoln was
living in the White House on January 1st
oh God
well that's the more important of the
two proclamations but what we do know is
Senator James rude Doolittle and
Postmaster General Montgomery Blair
visited him the night before in the
White House Blair writes it down in his
diary and says we visited the president
we were up till midnight debating
colonization in this scheme that he was
about to watch the next day
so we do know where he was I do think it
matters though in the case of dunmore's
proclamation because inhabiting the
residents of the governor and the
capitol is a big deal it means you're
still in power it means you're still
presiding over the colony if you're
stuck on a ship out in the Chesapeake
Bay issuing orders at the shore that
your army is no longer control and your
government is no longer present in you
know that's not like shouting into the
wind
I don't want to diminish it other than
to know the dunmore's proclamation is a
very opportunistic last-ditch effort I
think Professor Holton would agree with
me on that which is entirely fair to
consider what it comes down to is the
British and American governments both
used African-Americans opportunistically
throughout the world four we know from
the Phillipsburg Declaration of 1779
which was the second of the major
British efforts to enlist slaves into
the army they did so the opening line
says we want to enlist slaves because
these rebellious colonists are using
their slaves in their armies
and it also declares you know if we
capture any of their slaves or former
slaves that are in their armies we can
re-enslave them and we'll sell them
toward the war effort
it's a pretty horrific thing to do but
it's also evidence of the opportunism
nonetheless we do have bright shining
moments
of abolitionism showing throughout
throughout the American Revolution as
early as 1763 James Otis Mr no taxation
without representation
writes that the principles of natural
right extend to both black and white
people
and he's a major advocate of that
probably one of the first true
abolitionists of the country yes there
are slave owners on the American side
yes there are slave owners on the
British side banister Tarleton the
notorious Calvary commander of General
Cornwallis is a Scion of one of the
leading slave trade families of
Liverpool and spends the remainder of
his career after he doesn't establish a
foothold in the colonies because he's
expelled
being the main advocate of slavery and
defender of it in the British Parliament
let's turn to the economics you know the
question was posed if not caught and
what else
well there's the trick there is no
single industry that explains
industrialization across world history
this is something that economic
historians have known and debated and
investigated and empirically tested for
generations going all the way back to
the work of Robert Fogle in the 1960s
when the original theory was it wasn't
caught in that industrialized America it
was railroads in fact he subjects this
to empirical tests and he finds not only
our railroads too small to explain the
industrial pattern that followed but the
other competitor industry steamships
canals other means of Transport were
almost as efficient at moving Goods as
railroads we find the same thing if we
investigate cotton a generation earlier
other crops other Staples in fact an
argument was made on the eve of the
American Civil War that the South had
become so path dependent on Cotton it
was misusing and misallocating land and
they found that after the Civil War when
they transferred Crop Production to
other crops they grew better in some
regions than cotton because the slaves
have system had been cast off it had
created that path dependency so we asked
what's the opportunity cost there it
turns out no single industry explains
all of American industrialization
no I do want to I guess the question was
posed to me about what my evidence was
uh that martial law was a major driver
of the colonists response to dunmore's
Proclamation again this might be a
trivial point it might not be but I want
to be historically accurate here I don't
have access to every document so I can't
quote it right off the top of my head
but I do know and have read the Virginia
House of burgess's response to Doug's
Proclamation where they lay out the
order of grievances against it yes
slavery is in there it is the fourth
item
on the list item number one of their
grievances is he has declared martial
law across the colony and in fact that
Declaration of Martial law infuriated
people on both sides those that were
already taking up arms those that had
not it even infuriated some loyalists
other complication of that you find out
the loyalists in the colony of Virginia
are by no means opponents of slavery in
fact quite
probably the majority of them relocate
to the Caribbean after the war why
because that's where slavery persists
and they re-establish their own
plantations there what they had intended
to do just like Governor Dunmore
intended to do if he had ever reclaimed
The Colony he did have a landing party
once at some point in the summer of 1775
where he brought a few Marines back onto
Shore from his ship Exile what did he do
he visited his Plantation Portobello up
the uh the river and decided to hold a
dinner party for his generals a dinner
party served on by his slaves that he
had relocated there really interesting
piece of History
a rebellious writing party catches wind
that the governor has arrived on Shore
again and they send out Scouts to
surround the plantation he catches word
and flees in his row boat back to his
ship and off into the Chesapeake
that is not a sign of a man in power
that is not a sign of someone who can
even issue proclamations that could be
acted upon that is a sign of someone who
has already lost control months prior to
what the 1619 project is asserting in
its text in asserting in its Hulu series
I do think it is important to give a
fuller picture because if you only give
a partial picture you only give a
depiction that shows this one event
occurring on the streets of Williamsburg
pointing at the governor's Palace and
suggesting that it comes from an
inhabitant of that building
well what happens
that becomes the new narrative that
supplants what really occurred
historically
and what's missing from that the whole
other side of the story that would
suggest slavery in all of its
complexities
crisscrossed every line of the American
Revolution
had complexities that put slave owners
against
emancipationists and abolitionists
manumissionists
people who are philosophically hostile
to the institution people who were
philosophically supportive of it or on
all sides of the revolution
it's a tragedy of a horrific institution
which slavery absolutely was
but there is a silver lining it got a
discussion going underway that's not
brought to the Forefront of the 1619
project especially its revised forms and
that discussion is the path toward
emancipation because there are at least
some people in the colonies that realize
slavery is inconsistent with all
principles and philosophical grounds
that they were stating as their basis
for Independence
that set that ball into motion starting
in 1777 in Vermont and continuing all
the way to the eve of the Civil War when
the somerset ruling is used by
abolitionists to fight a little Supreme
Court case called Dred Scott versus
Sanford Unfortunately they lose but that
was the True Legacy of abolition that
carries forth from the revolution today
foreign
thank you guys we now go to the the Q a
uh section of the evening and uh anybody
wants to ask the question can line up
behind the microphone uh meanwhile uh
let me take uh moderator's prerogative
to ask a couple of questions uh first uh
let me start with you what a question to
ask both of you basically uh a division
between you is that if I understand
quickly Woody you do maintain along with
the 1619 project that uh the defense of
slavery of the institution of slavery
was an important cause of the American
Revolution is that correct and if so
would you elaborate on that yeah the
only thing I'd qualify about that is I
don't like that phrase institution of
slavery okay I think and that's
important because it sounds like if
you're going after an institution it's
different from what dunmore's
Proclamation was and he referred to the
Phillipsburg proclamation of July 17th
87 as well those were expedience War
measures that's what you do when you
don't care about the institutions you
care about winning your War you see what
I mean so that's those are those are
offers to enslaved people come join me
but they're not trying to tear down the
whole institution and so I think the in
the original 2019 version the six the
1619 project aired in Nicole Hannah
Jones did in her in her introduction to
that aired in using that phrase
institution of slavery I know if she got
it she got it from Lincoln because
Lincoln was always talking about the
institution of slavery which of course
he did personally oppose although the
north didn't oppose it at the start of
the war so anyway she picked up that
phrase institution of slavery and I
think she now more correctly says I know
she now says in the book uh that this
was a war measure and and that really
goes to something that Phil was just
talking about he's saying the British
were horrific and opportunistic and I
hope I made it clear before you said
that that I completely agree it was a
war measure so so that's the only thing
I'd qualify about the way you defined it
I'd give you more evidence okay
just slavery maybe I misunderstood was
the were the colonists fighting the
revolution
for an important reason to maintain
slavery or no was that isn't that a is
that this sounds like a it sounds like
I'm quibbling about the language but
people people rebelled because they were
furious at the British
for stirring up their slaves against you
imagine you have kids Gene you do have
kids he's helping here so if I gave your
kid a gun and hypnotized him and said
shoot Gene you'd be
slightly angry at me
um and you know remember remember the uh
what was that movie with uh uh uh oh
shoot The Manchurian Candidate oh that's
basically the way white saw what was
going on the British have hit our slaves
love us we're just like a family I treat
them so well and now the British have
hypnotized them I gave you that one
quote about the about the knife I have
six different people who use different
versions of they're getting our slaves
to Slit our throats they're getting our
slaves to chop off our heads there was a
lot of this knife on Fort
phraseology from Georgia to through
South Carolina North Carolina Virginia
so okay okay so slave anger slavery was
a significant cause of the American
Revolution yes I I know I'm sound like
I'm quibbling slaves were slaves by
initiating this alliance with the
British slaves were in a significant
cause of the American Revolution in
nursing this alliance with the British
yes a comment from you Phil you do you
disagree with that
so I think it's a complicated question
here
um I think there are elements to agree
upon that slavery certainly manifests as
well throughout the American Revolution
we've seen them we've been discussing
them here tonight
but the debate topic is about the 1619
project is presented in this book in
this Hulu series and I'm going to return
to that you do not get that complexity
in the way that the Hulu series is
presenting this chain of events in fact
someone a school student in grade five
could be watching this as part of their
educational curriculum which the New
York Times has conveniently rolled out
and pushed into classrooms
I mean that's part of a reasonable
debate to have but a student could be
watching that and the takeaway they
think is that dunmore's a good guy
why because it's not discussed if we can
play the clip again I never said he was
a good guy we never implied that he was
a good guy well there's no indication he
said or done more own slaves there's no
indication that after the American
Revolution he is reappointed as governor
of the Bahamas and promptly goes to
fortifying the the island of Nassau with
forced coerced slave labor that he drew
off of the plantation we didn't talk
about the Bahamas we didn't talk about
Jamaica Barbados well we didn't talk
about any of these places in the
Caribbean because we were talking about
that about what happened next you've
done these things you've seen how easily
somebody can screw up because of all the
screw-ups that you made in that clip
that I played people but we didn't screw
up see what he's pointed out you're back
you're back at the you're back at the
conveniently omitted talk about what
people did say not about what they
didn't yeah well if you're omitting
two-thirds of the story or three-fourths
of the story which is what we see here
in Lord Dunmore a school student to tell
me if you had a five-year a fifth grader
that watched that video clip would they
think Dunmore is a good or a bad guy I
guarantee you if you hold the room most
of them think he's probably the good guy
okay just one final question from me and
then I would go to the audience uh
unless you guys want to ask each other a
question uh the the issue of Cotton's
role in the economy you quoted what a uh
Cotton's share of exports but then Phil
said well exports were a minor share of
U.S GDP at the time would you do
basically agree with the figure that
Phil put forward that in terms of actual
GDP output cotton was about five percent
so therefore the other 95 percent was
not gotten well if you agree with that
most of that 90 first five percent is
home production for home consumption
home production for home consumption I
grow grain the man grows grain the woman
grows vegetables and there's no
factories in the north there's no cattle
production of course there are there are
and but what are those factories gene
they are cotton textile mills that's the
dominant industry that's the beginning
so railroads of course become a bigger
thing and all the steel to go on the
railroads that that comes later though
what is the beginning of industry it's
in every textbook that you know the the
first it's the Paul Tuckett Rhode Island
Mill of Samuel's what's his name Samuel
something Samuel Slater in Pawtucket and
then the the Waltham Associates and then
we get Lowell and you can go I'd really
encourage you guys to go up to Lowell
Massachusetts where National Park
Service has an amazing site there where
you can they're actually still running
those water powered spinning Jenny's
that's the beginning of it why are we
denying things that are so obvious why
are we denying things about Black's role
in the revolution which we've known
since 1950 okay well okay all right
it said it's five percent of GDP but the
GDP was just a lot of Home production
okay no not all there was other there
was there was external production like
the cotton textile mills but you agree
that it was grown cotton and turned it
into cloth for slavery that it was five
percent of U.S GDP yeah I can't question
GNP numbers GDP but but well for
instance oil now is five percent there's
a little over five percent of our uh he
gives different numbers but but they're
in the same range oil today and so would
you say oil production don't say this in
Texas Gene but would you say oil
production is not an important part of
our economy today
well it's okay yeah all right I see your
point anyway so Phil comment from you no
my opponent is pointing out anecdotes of
specific factories I'm pointing to
statistics I'm pointing to data GDP is
defined as all output of the U.S economy
in a given year if 95 of all output of
finished goods is coming from other
things we've already built into the
calculation these intermediate steps
that's the error that's made by these
new historians of capitalism let's say
the era that's made in the 1619 project
is they only want to look at
intermediate steps of production when
it's tied to Cotton and slavery they
don't want to look at other other
products what was bigger than cotton was
very it would depend on the year in any
year just get in here and tell me
something at 19. 1850 51 all the way up
to 60 1860. tell me a bigger commodity
produced in America I I'd have to go
back and look at the specific stats in
the books uh I know in some years the
railroad industry is larger than that
there are major production centers in
Pennsylvania of iron and later steel
there's major woven textile factories in
New England there's glass there's land
trees which is cotton right we could
agree that that's cotton it's only
adding value it's not creating value
it's adding it but that goes in the
cotton column if it's coming from wool
it's coming from Sheep Growers in
Vermont of course no you didn't say that
you said and Mississippi but we're
talking about finished goodlets so if
we're making a statistical an empirical
claim you have to treat I'm surprised
that an economic historian in the 19th
century can't name us says that that
cotton is small because it's around five
it would depend on the year you can't
name a single other commodity that sold
well I don't have a book here where I
want to make it in I don't want to make
an End wouldn't it be at the top of your
head yeah off the top of my head I gave
you several industries that are very
large in the same range give me one
that's bigger than cotton because you're
saying it's small again
you're asking me to memorize a
statistical manual in the United States
one commodity is bigger than cotton okay
well all right we used to have stuck on
that uh uh any questions from the
audience please ask a question like a
question question for Woody so I think
you said or in the in the film you
claimed that
um cotton production was the primary
driver of or the main cause of the
Industrial Revolution something to that
effect first that's right it's the
beginning of the Industrial Revolution
now really slave grown molasses getting
converted into rum in the 18th century
well since my Century the one I
specialize in um but in the 19th century
when we think of Indus industry getting
going it's the cotton textile mills
and I'm sorry that I named a couple of
them of course there were thousands
well so the problem I have with that is
if
cotton was only five percent of total
U.S GDP output cotton exports at SSA
um there's sounds like there can be
Myriad other
outputs of production aspects of the
economy that are contributing right much
more significantly in total I think
industrialization so we're talking about
a time when 90 of Americans enslaved and
free were farmers and of course in the
South farmers are growing commodities
for export tobacco in my home state of
Virginia cotton south of there and so
forth but most of those farmers were
growing grain and um in most people were
self-sufficient in food and all of that
goes into the GNP figure so that's how
you get cotton down to five percent the
better number and I don't know this
number and I know that Phil doesn't
either the better number is of the stuff
that got traded that left the farm and
left the village and got out into the uh
not even leaving the country but in in
within the country the stuff that got
traded what percentage of that was raw
cotton but then also the value that's
added by the factories in New England
and New York Pennsylvania was actually
the number one cotton textile industry
at the height of it Pennsylvania so you
add that value you see what I'm saying
within the stuff that's traded cotton
would be much much more than five
percent but I'm not going to risk a
number but did you get to see what I'm
saying it's a it's not entirely uh
subsistence economy but it's much more
of a subsistence economy than now
everything I'm wearing right now I
bought
you see what I mean I didn't make any of
this stuff but that wouldn't be true of
me 150 years ago
comment for you Phil on there
well nothing in that statistical claim
is accurate though there is a vast
internal Market in the United States of
food stuff going from Ohio to New York
City sure the cities you have to eat
from somewhere they can't grow corn in
the garden in the back of their uh
townhouse I mean there may be some
examples of that today in some very
small homegrown things but uh you know
we're talking in that era this isn't
just because you know what percentage of
people lived in cities don't you yes
yeah exactly and where is the
agriculture in the country at the time
where are the immigrants from the old
world going to in the New World
the vast majority of them settle in
northern states and take up farming in
northern states why because that's where
the economy was unless you were at the
very tip top of the economic
distribution you were a large Plantation
owner most likely in the South you are
either enslaved or you are a poor white
person
if you're in the north you have a chance
to make something of yourself and that's
where the Immigrant flows tend to go
that is a vote of confidence with their
feet where the economic activity is it's
not there to just grow food for
themselves it's because they see a
pathway to wealth they see a pathway to
making a life for themselves
um let me join another issue Woody that
step in a moment again as uh as
moderator
taking prerogative
post
1870 the the argument has been
maintained that the northern economy
boomed did very well the South was
wrecked so so if the southern cotton
industry was so necessary to the broad
economy how could the north do so well
once the South was wrecked wouldn't that
have been a test kit if the South was so
vital to it then went the north of in
wrecked too because it lost its Lifeline
that wonderful cotton that you say is so
important they hadn't lost their
Lifeline more ex more there was more
cotton grown in United States in 1870
then in 1850. so same people as you know
reconstruction was overthrown and the
people who had been the slaves on the
plantations became the sharecroppers on
the plantations in a condition very
similar to slavery enforced by violence
things like the Wilmington race riot the
destruction of Tulsa so the South was
still a functioning part of the economy
okay fair enough yeah and this game can
I just say real quickly because I'm
really glad you you know the term under
development I think this the north
definitely underdeveloped the South and
poor whites suffered from that not as
much as as the blacks whom they were
lynching suffered from it but they
suffered from it as well we've seen we
we know about underdevelopment why there
is a third world in the first world one
reason we're so rich is that they're so
poor that is uh they're uh it's not
entirely a zero-something but
um we've our businesses have profited by
moving to Mexico where they pay much
lower wages and so forth and so that
same process happens with within the
borders of the United States as well the
the I think it's fair to say just as
there's a wonderful book by Manning
Maribel how Europe underdeveloped Africa
we could also talk about how the north
underdeveloped the South now that's not
to say the entire South got
underdeveloped because it put James
Henry ham and he mentioned was one of
these filthy rich planters
but uh could you come in on that filled
it now
this is an odd argument to say the south
boomed after slavery in its production
of cotton then the numbers of bales that
are produced uh isn't really very good
evidence that slavery was necessary to
or essential to the production of cotton
yes conditions and reconstruction are
horrible but they are still an
improvement over slavery and I think we
could all agree to that uh that's bad
but certainly better than what came
before it and yet economically we also
have evidence across the American South
that it does stagnate for Generations
you can go down to the county level and
find counties that had higher
concentrations of slave plantations
before the Civil War lagged economically
for a century after the counties of the
South that had small slave populations
yeah that shows that there is something
rotten about this institution it causes
underdevelopment it causes poverty it
causes the misallocation of land it
causes industry to never developed there
so far is that uh the reach of that
horrific Institution
that a century later the South remains
lagging behind the rest of the country
and only in recent decades has started
to catch up
and in some cases overtake it
that's evidence of slavery's
impoverishing effect not its wealth
aggrandizing effect which is the thesis
of the 1690s it's bad for all those
people I totally agree that you
mentioned except for the capitalists
but the slave owners themselves were not
capitalists they would have recoiled at
the very suggestion that said
capitalists are the owners of the
factory up in the north in fact that's
what George Fitzhugh declares multiple
times he says these exploitative Capital
owners in the factories of the north
have an inferior system to what we have
this noblesse of liege slave plantation
system on the south it's a throwback to
feudalism
it's a throwback to an older system that
the southerners saw Superior this was
James Henry Hammond's point in the King
Cotton mud seal speech that Abraham
Lincoln attacks Abraham Lincoln points
out that Free Labor is superior to slave
labor precisely because of capitalism
so I think it's very odd that we're now
applying this term capitalism to people
who in no conception would have
considered themselves capitalists in the
19th century and in fact would have
denounced in Outrage possibly pulled out
a gun and challenge to someone to a duel
if they call the slave owner a
capitalist in the 19th century can we
just quickly respond to that in the same
way that I don't don't let slaveholders
tell me what to call their slaves I
don't let them tell me what to call them
either and for me a guy who makes
Investments and calculates whether he's
made gains or losses whether he's doing
it on a farm or whether he's building
ships in Boston or whether he's sending
ships all over the world from
Philadelphia is a capitalist the gulags
of the Soviet Union kept accounting
books they calculated what came out of
them in production they calculated sales
they calculated Returns on individual
laborers prisoners that were held there
against their will and forced to work
was the Soviet Union a capitalist
Society by that definition it is
capitalist
today has elements of it but it also has
elements of basically enslavement so the
good stuff we call capitalism and the
bad stuff we call not I'm not making a
value judgment on that I'm asserting
that that there are elements at play it
both China is a very complex mixed
system and I think at its worst times is
where it Strays furthest from a a free
market free labor exchange but I do
think there are basic definitions we
have to agree upon there was another
clip in the 1619 project Hulu series I
didn't show but they have this big
discussion between Nicole Hannah Jones
and a couple of her expert guests these
new historians of capitalism and she
asked them to find capitalism and they
waver around they play word games and
they never really can offer a true
definition of what constitutes
capitalism uh but then they come to a
conclusion says nonetheless capitalism's
weighted at the hip to slavery and it's
exploitative
that's dodging the question here if we
don't have a functional definition how
can you make that claim
next question uh first I'd like to thank
both of you for a very vigorous
stimulating and informative debate thank
you
my question is I apologize in advance
maybe a bit abstract but I want briefly
to go back to Professor holton's opening
statement and Dr magnus's opening
statements one thing that it seemed to
me characterized uh sort of the general
tenor of Professor holton's opening
statements was an emphasis on facts that
were less known
fact that if they were more widely known
might give people the correct impression
compared to a certain sort of
mythologized History of the United
States that race and the legacy of
slavery cut much more deeply across the
history of this country than in certain
again mythologized versions of History
at the same time Dr magnus's opening
statement emphasized what I might call
historiographical concerns and
historiographical critiques of the again
latter version or latter iterations of
the 1619 project this sort of warmed
over version of the new historians of
capitalism claims about the origins of
at least the American Industrial
Revolution these claims about the
origins of the Revolutionary War
relative you know balances of different
causes in the origins uh and the
specific conduct of that war
and then afterwards things took an
interesting turn and and for the end
just as well Professor Holton you
brought up uh many particular facts
there was we got into a discussion of
details
um and details that matter and certainly
I I I'm paraphrasing I apologize you
said something to the effect that some
of these details like is it November
this and that not that chronology never
matters but sometimes a secondary to the
broader uh import could you get to the
question yes I'm I'm almost there I
apologize so my question is when we talk
about the importance of the 16 19 19
project as a matter of public history to
what extent is the disagreement about
the relative importance of changing
historiography or popular perceptions of
historiography and a broader narrative
versus bringing uh facts to broader
awareness that people might have just
been totally ignorant of and where would
each of you think we draw the line on
when the uh the project might be net a
malign influence or net a beneficial one
thank you
okay there was a complicated question
can you put your mind around it
Professor Holton
um
I can take a take a stab at that uh I've
long said that one of the great
tragedies of the 1619 project is the
missed opportunity it had
and the original version that came out
in the New York Times how many of you
know any other author besides Nicole
Hannah Jones or Matthew Desmond
show of hands maybe one or two of you
no one really knows there's a dozen or
so different other authors that had very
interesting important and in fact
credible scholarly contributions and a
wide variety of subjects ranging from
music to incarceration to poetry and
literature to other aspects of History
besides this era between
1775 and 1865 roughly when uh slavery is
at its peak in the United States but all
we know about are those two essays why
because the political debate around them
has drowned out the remainder
and it's drowned out the remainder
precisely I would argue because it's
focused on scoring talking points to
reorient
United States history and in fact I can
show you some evidence of this so I'll
save it on the closing but one of the
claims that Nicole Hannah Jones made at
the outset and continues in various
forms in the book is that her aim was to
supplant 1776 as the founding year of
America with the year 1619. it's a
pretty bold historical claim but it's a
claim that's made on rhetorical bases
not historiographical bases and if we're
just arguing rhetoric we're just
throwing up talking points and yet
saying this is how we're supposed to
teach history I think there's quite a
bit of the story that's lost that's left
out the enriching value of History comes
from exactly those details that are
neglected omitted and conveniently left
out because they go against the
narrative she was trying to tell
first of all you want to make a comment
oh yeah and I'm going to answer your
question but
um you remind me of something I wanted
to ask you before Phil which is an
answering that question you say how much
better it was you're now saying it was
so much better it was in 2019 than into
2021 what got setting aside the ones
we've already talked about Nicole Hina
Jones and uh and uh Matthew Desmond what
tell me specific things that got worse
than the other articles
I think there's the interesting thing
about it uh well she did add new
articles to the books there's an entire
chapter yeah but then the ones the ones
that you liked in 2019 but most of them
were repeated verbatim and I repeat no
no it's not verbatim I'll tell you the
changes I uh noticed a minute well I'll
tell you real quick they got more
careful because of you and people like
me and pat yourself on the back but I
didn't critique those they made a lot of
they made a lot well I don't mean you
wouldn't specify I think the Desmond
stuff you get a lot of credit for and
other and me I mean I made I got them
off the somerset uh thing all that never
mentioned Somerset in 2019 to be fair to
them
um but they so they're more careful
they're also angrier and there's a
reason for that 2019 2021 what happened
in the middle George Floyd and of course
an unarmed black man gets killed by a
police officer at least once a week
anyway but that one got attention and
and so there's a real interesting I've
had that's one of the things I did with
my students I had them read 6019 Project
Read a bunch of the critics of it and
also read the both the the magazine
version and the book version and compare
different students to different chapters
and compared that same author and they
know I'm saying what I'm saying now
based on what I learned from the yeah
but you found them you found the 2019
version you're now saying of these
articles better than the 21 version so
setting aside the new ones which we
can't make a comparison setting aside
Hannah Nicole Hannah Jones and Matthew
Desmond which we've already talked about
let's talk about some of the others and
what changed and what got worse
well
I think the infusion of political
rhetoric has done a difficult for the
project well he said the tone of all the
articles in general was it was angrier
that's not very specific yeah I mean do
you want you to be specific because
that's how you started this whole thing
off oh I kind of like the 20 the 2019
version in the New York Times magazine
and then the Articles got worse for 2021
in the book which one got specific got
bad in which way no I just asking
Desmond's articles now give us Jones our
article got significant of course how
did that Matthew Desmond Imports this no
no no you've already talked about
Desmond I I hear you well all right so
how did Desmond get worse we'll go back
to Desmond because I don't think you can
answer it for anybody else right I'm not
going to try to make a claim on the
others that's the thing but you're just
going to say it's worse you're not gonna
make any evidence the entire project has
drowned out valuable contributions by
other historians because these two
essays are not only significantly we're
just talking about the two that's what
you really meant Matthew Desmond say
what is it worse uh he Imports in the
place of these bad statistics that he
got called out on in fact he did not
give me credit I have an email from Jake
Silverstein the editor of the New York
Times magazine that says we did not make
Corrections in response to you
that's kind of strange if I'm supposed
to get all the credit but what does he
do he Imports a very rigid Marxist
theory from early 20th century
historiography first proffered by a
fellow by the name of earner sombard in
a 1905 book called moderna capitalismus
it basically says that slavery divides
the proletarian classes of the United
States and prevents the emergence of a
socialist Revolution he adds that claim
as his tie together mechanism to
supplant what he thinks is wrong about
American capitalism this is very very
Fringe history that he's arguing there
he makes secondary and tertiary claims
around that says that the reason the
United States is a relative latecomer to
having a federal income tax is because
of the pernicious influence of slavery
this is a completely a historical claim
if you go back to the ratification votes
of the 16th Amendment guess which states
ratified first it was the states of the
old Confederacy because they thought the
income tax would put more of the tax
burden on the industrial Northeast than
themselves okay let's go to another
question
sorry big picture question as has been
noted the New York could you maybe sit
the mic up a little bit
big picture question as has been noted
the New York Times said their reason for
issuing this was they wanted to
re-center the start of U.S history
around 1619 and not 1776. big picture
would that be healthier for society or
less healthy oh I'll take this one if
you don't mind you can go um the uh
we're not there is no Academy American
that's going to decide as there is in
France you know they have an academy
francaise that tells you how to spell Vu
and two and everything else but not in
America and thank God not in America so
my point is if you want to say 1776 and
she wants to say 1619 uh I would say
1523 when the first Africans arrived in
North America because so much of what
makes America America are our black
people even racist acknowledge in
culture and sports and all that but
politically do you know that Texas and
Florida wouldn't be part of the union
now since they both ban the 1619 project
there's sort of irony in that but both
of them join the union in part because
of slavery that is we wanted Florida so
that slaves couldn't run away there
Texas left Mexico because Mexico
wouldn't let them have slaves so I would
go for 1523 when our first African
people arrived here it's a game I could
also say 1780 because half of our
African ancestors arrived before that
date half of our African ancestors
arrived after 1780 the equivalent date
for our European ancestors is 1900 120
years later it's a fun game to play and
I uh and and so if it's done in a spirit
of of of not playing not being silly but
but but making the case I I have no
issue with it because I think 1776 is
important both because of what whites
were doing and because of what blacks
were doing which was freeing themselves
in the north eventually by joining the
Americans but then in the South where 90
of African-Americans lived by joining
the British
um comment from you Phil about that I'll
be real quick I'll say 1662 is a good
candidate year that's when slavery is
racialized on legal codification in
Virginia by the part of sequitur ventrum
Doctrine it was distinguished from
indentured servitude this sets the
southern colonies on the pathway toward
slavery becoming institutionalized on
racial grounds but again that's an
important part of the story that's an
important part of the Nuance it's later
added into the book and some of the
discussion but that would have been an
interesting starting point in fact a
more interesting starting point than the
claims that are made but it doesn't have
the same political salience of declaring
this year 1619 should supplant 1776 in
the way that it was used
very quickly
those of you lined up for questions I'm
sorry we don't have any more time uh at
the party afterwards these very
approachable guys will be at the party
and so you can color them buttonhole
them about your points and ask them
questions further we want to go to the
summation portion of the evening Woody
take it away five minutes of summary
okay
um I really love that last question uh
what is the the the best uh date
um because that's our discussion uh that
I confess I've never had with my student
oh no I think I did in one class once
but it's one I should probably have with
my students more often what date would
you choose
um and I should say that the reason she
chose 1619 because her world changed
when a book was put into her hands and
can I ask how many of you have heard of
a book by lerone Bennett Jr called
before the Mayflower
one two Beverly you haven't my
daughter's here I'm Paul she's never
heard of before the Mayflower well also
four or five people maybe
um uh he titled it that it was it was a
very early black history book published
in 1962 and it was pointing out the
Mayflower landed in 1620 so just before
but before the Mayflower was when these
Africans were landed in the English
colony of Virginia and that book really
changed her life and set her on she's
now a professor but she's won the
MacArthur uh genius Grant she's won the
uh the uh the Pulitzer Prize she's now
professor at Howard uh and so and and
she's on on a mission you can see by the
way it doesn't bother me that she's on a
mission it doesn't bother me that Phil's
on this Mission Against The 1619 project
he's got a different Mission about about
uh Lincoln and I say more power to you
even though I like Lincoln I think he
changed and became a much a better
person
um that I like books that Advocate and I
want them in our classrooms and one of
the things I really admire about Phil
Magnus is even though he's a
conservative he opposed I saw you say it
on that podcast the censorship he's
standing up to Rhonda Santos which I
think is a pretty brave thing for any
conservative American to do and the
people in Texas sorry let's give my
answer that because we are all
Libertarians tonight
um and and that's what I want to say
about the 1619 project yeah there's a
lot to disagree with I think I showed
that they did fix most of the errors he
told us they were going to be that he
was going to find errors
um and what he mostly found was uh
differences of interpretation that he
had with two authors Nicole Hannah Jones
and Matthew Desmond we didn't get a lot
of errors in either the book or the TV
show again the only person who goofed up
in the TV show was me and mayor culpa so
there's not a lot of errors in it but
there's a lot of opinions and they
acknowledge that and that's what I want
in the classroom I want to keep being
able because right now if I lived in
Florida or Texas I could assign bills
but Phil's book criticizing the 1619
project but I couldn't assign the 16 19
in fact I might get in trouble for
signing yours because you quote him a
lot
is that the country that we want to live
in and I want to tell you one more thing
about the classroom first I want to
invite everybody here to drop in on my
class don't call me ahead because then I
might do something special for you just
show up in any class that I teach at the
University of South Carolina if you're
ever in Columbia I think you can do that
in New York as well you will be
pleasantly surprised because I think a
lot of my conservative friends think
that what's going on in that classroom
is that we are indoctrinating uh
students into our own wacko ideology and
the actuality don't believe your own
rhetoric because the actuality of the
American classroom today and I'm talking
about mine at the University of South
Carolina my daughters are in a public
high school in the suburbs they're
actual their actual situation is we are
moving away from indoctrination and
toward assigning primary sources and
getting the students to debate them in
the same way that Phil and I have
debated them tonight and also so to
answer the historiography question that
I dodged before yeah I get my students
even in their first year I expose them
to all the different interpretations not
all as many as I can of the
interpretations of Witchcraft and they
have to argue which one best fits the
evidence of the primary source that
they've read that's what we're really
doing in the classrooms we're not saying
you will be Communists like me we are
getting them arguing with each other
based on evidence and among those pieces
of evidence that I have found that has
inspired students and feel you'll love
this this when I the one time I've
assigned the 60 19 project I wanted them
to read the critics I found the best
critics I could but almost all of them
agreed with the book and so guess who
played the role of Phil McGinnis in that
classroom it was me thank you
[Applause]
I think when he called you Phil
McGuinness so Mr McGinnis please take
over
all right
first of all I want to start by thanking
Professor Holton for a very vibrant
Lively debate I think this has been a
productive evening and I want to thank
all of you for attending uh
I do want to return though to the prompt
of this debate because the question is
not whether the 1619 project should be
in classrooms that's a political
question
the question is whether the specific
book in Hulu series versions are
important contributions to our
understanding of slavery I started on
the point by saying that the original
version of the 1619 project had an
opportunity to start exactly that type
of conversation and I'm going to go back
to the day that I first opened the New
York Times that morning in August of
2019 and noticed they had a new a new
series out on slavery I was originally
very excited to see that series not only
because I worked on the subject matter
but because it hearkened back to the
last time the New York Times did a
serious substantive journalistic project
on the history of slavery it was only a
few years prior to that between 2011 and
2015 the New York Times ran over a
thousand short form
op-ed style historical investigations of
the 150th anniversary of the American
Civil War and issues surrounding it of
which slavery is the centerpiece the
central issue of the Civil War it
investigated it in a format that debated
both sides
it investigated in the format that
explored deep historiographical
controversies over the Civil War
it looked at the pernicious extension of
slavery into the present day it looked
at it retrospectively into the past and
it did it very very well
the 1619 project could have been that
could have been another expansion of
that type of a series that included not
only the Civil War era it extended back
to the American Revolution or extended
back to Colonial days the arrival of
that first ship off the coast of
Jamestown in 1619 could have done that
very effectively they chose not to
because they only wanted one specific
narrative represented and when other
historians jumped into the debate as
critics it was not to tear down
the 1619 project it was to jump start
that type of a debate
how did Nicole Hannah Jones and in
particular how did Jake Silverstein the
editor of the magazine respond to those
critics well I happen to know because I
was one of them I was one of the first
people that wrote an economic response
to Matt Desmond's essay and of course
what did I do I pointed out the
Microsoft Excel claim that turned out to
be a flat out historical era
as I was commenting on that in the
public scene I also submitted a letter
to the New York Times seeking a formal
correction
it made it its way all the way to Jake
Silverstein's desk he responded to me by
email and I thank him for his response I
don't thank him for the content you know
what his response was well we've looked
at the two pieces side by side this
claim about Microsoft Excel in the book
that in fact he claimed it was based on
that says the exact opposite of
Microsoft Excel and he says this is only
a difference of interpretation
and that has been the line of the 1619
project in the face of criticism ever
since
if you go through the entire history of
the last three or four years since this
series first appeared in the New York
Times you find something really
interesting even though they dance
around concessions and nuances in
addition of sources they never outright
admit error
or if they do they heavily qualify it
and then they walk it back
they heavily qualified in such a way
that I'll show you right here
this was intended to be my last slide of
the original series
this was how all the New York Times the
1619 project appeared on its website the
day it was published
in August 2019 about that claim of
whether 1619 should replace the American
founding you can see it underlined right
there in August 2019. about a year later
Nicole Hannah Jones was being challenged
on that particular line because it
stirred up quite a bit of controversy
and she went on CNN
and I was watching this live and I'm
still aghast at what she said she says I
never made that claim I don't know where
you got that from
and of course myself and several
journalists historians see this
happening in real time she's denying she
ever made that claim and we start
scratching our heads because we all
remembered her making that exact claim I
went to an archived version of the
website and found it there and then I
reopened the original 1619 project it
had been ghost edited the claim had been
taken out the claim had been deleted and
she was challenged on that by one of her
co-editors Brett Stevens this is her
response there were no stealth
Corrections
that's not an error of interpretation
that is a lie and those types of lies
are pervasive in the subsequent
modifications of the 1619 project
they're pervasive even to the point
after the book came out I asked Jake
Silverstein again the editor why didn't
you acknowledge these errors in your
revisions why didn't you credit them he
says well they're just differences of
interpretation again so they want to
have one story that says they're being
responsive in another story that says
that they were never wrong in the first
place and in fact are trying to double
down on that claim of never being wrong
I think that's a disservice to history
because it teaches people the LIE
thank you
well uh we now go to the final voting I
have in my hand the soil Forum Tootsie
Roll
see role
this is the best we could do the uh the
soil form 50 year old authentic Tootsie
Roll edible for sure but of course you
don't want to eat it you want to save it
because if you win it it's invaluable
and it will go to whoever moves the
needle the New York Times book The 1619
project and the hula video series based
on it or important contributions to our
understanding of slavery and the role of
African Americans in American history
you are now voting your final vote yes
no or undecide undecided on the
resolution and while you vote let me
again invite both Debaters to our future
debates next time you're passing through
New York City possibly on May 22nd when
Northwestern University professor of Law
and philosophy will uh Andrew koppelman
will defend the resolution
libertarianism has been thoroughly
corrupted by delusion greed and disdain
for the weak Andrew Kaufman will defend
that resolution
taking the negative will be me that's on
Monday May 22nd and that debate will be
moderated by Nick Gillespie since I'll
have to recuse myself from the role of
moderator since I'll be a debater June
19th to 25th we are taking a show on the
road as we have in past Junes for the
third year in a row we're going up to
the porcupine Freedom Festival in
Lancaster New Hampshire otherwise known
as pork fest some who denigrated call it
Pig Fest it's a very Lively occasion in
an open field with many tents and many
other places I'm going to stay at a
hotel as will my assistant but drive to
the place hundreds and hundreds of young
people especially actually actively
having a porcupine Festival the term
porcupine I gather was devised to
describe a Libertarian a porcupine will
only hurt you if you hurt the porcupine
again I gather is the logic of them
calling themselves porcupines this is in
Lancaster New Hampshire if you go on the
website porcupine Freedom Festival you
will find listed my debate with the
illustrious and widely published son of
Milton Friedman that's David Friedman he
will defend the resolution slightly
wordy but I guess you get the point the
right way to persuade people of
libertarianism is by showing them that
its outcomes are superior without any
resort to the flawed non-aggression
principle that will be the affirmative
resolution that David will defend and
again taking the negative will be me
another debate that we're going to hold
will be between Jeremy Kaufman of of the
of the free state project of New
Hampshire versus Matt Kibby on the
resolution it is easier to convert a
heterosexual to homosexuality than to
convert a non-libertarianism
non-libertarian to libertarianism
uh that would be defended by uh Jeremy
Kaufman and a post by Matt Kibby and
that will be a second soil form debate
we will be debating it is June it's the
summer some of our resolutions are going
to be a little bit Whimsical as you
might imagine uh when we were out in the
field at the porcupine festival and I'll
be doing an economic Workshop up at the
uh the porcupine Festival uh far less
humorous one about various economic data
that's again from June 19th to June 25th
uh and tickets are still available for
it uh well uh we are we we have other
debates booked on Tuesday July 25th but
I'm not going to make that announcement
you want to go on our website for all
our debates because I think that Jane is
giving me the results of the voting and
so I'm going to read them to you uh drum
roll please uh yeah thank you yeah
well you know you know the resolution
that Woody was defending it went from
21.6 percent of the vote to nearly 23
percent so so it picked up
he but it's a matter of how much votes
you pick up Woody
you picked up 1.4 percent that's the
number to beat uh and the no votes went
from 37 to 59. so the uh the Tootsie
Roll goes to Phil Magnus congratulations
and he dropped it
okay and now again you're all invited to
the party at my place at 55 great Jones
Street The Debaters will be there uh to
uh to for you to query and buttonhole
plenty of good food plenty of wine beer
and other uh drinks and please attend
and we'll see you soon Uptown two blocks
Uptown follow the crowds